you have a space in an industry that now
has a market cap collectively of
uh over two trillion dollars that did
not exist seven years ago right and i've
met now
hundreds of people who've had their
lives transformed economically including
a lot of creators who were producing
things and
were having a hard time accessing the
market because the media market in the
art market in particular very very
narrow and institutionalized
but through
nfts they've been able to command
incomes that they never could have
imagined you can have mechanics where a
creator gets paid for a resale in a way
that was never possible before you start
talking to these folks and you realize
wait a minute like you know some of you
have the equivalent of a universal basic
income some of you have the equivalent
of these kind of social economies that i
was writing about back in
2017-2018 that have come alive this is
to me one of the most profound
opportunities maybe the most profound
opportunity to fight poverty
that's on the table right now i mean
what are the other major opportunities
to fight poverty
lobby congress for the enhanced child
tax credit which we're doing but one of
the cases we're making
right now is that dc is kind of broken
and dysfunctional
you know
if that's your situation like you still
try and push push push you know and then
you try to reform the system
but you also look around and say wait
like that there are whole new economies
that are emerging that are being enabled
by digital currencies and other
innovations
so let's try and make the most of that
and if you have a space that's
worth trillions of dollars one of my
personal ambitions by coming in and
saying look we have to demonstrate that
this can be used to benefit the broader
public then maybe it's perceived to or
maybe that it is right now let's take
a billion and fight some poverty with it
and then show people what can be done i
mean a billion would be a very small
fraction of what's happening in web3
so i'm pumped about it
[Music]
this week on ford russia encroaching
possibly invading ukraine
web 3 our time at east denver and how we
think it can help modernize economies
and fight poverty
and follow up on the boy crisis my
conversation with dr farrell how does
the tinder swindler fit into it this
week on forward
[Music]
we're live it's happening
this
week podcast is on the road where on the
road you may ask if you're watching the
video you see it's sunny it's warm where
could we be
but the beautiful island of puerto rico
puerto rico and it's amazing
what's that do zack and andrew vacation
together
no not usually not usually no no we
don't have that kind of relationship but
this time we're doing a quasi work
retreat
uh carly is is here doing some web 3
work so there you know there's there are
all sorts of fun reasons to combine
forces here in puerto rico it is lovely
here it is lovely and for just for
anyone i cracked a beer a beer local
medalla light beer local puerto rico
gonna make the podcast interesting and
yeah carly cryptocarly is shooting um
her own version of
let's call it web3 meets parts unknown
and she's a you know a different type of
version of anthony bourdain
theoretically so yeah we're productive
the kids are here you might see you
might see a little yeah my kids might
wander around on the set
yeah good times well we're here welcome
back folks
now so the world's attention is on
the
situation with russia
invading ukraine or not invading
uh it certainly seems like an invasion
is imminent as of this recording
they had declared some of the separatist
territories to be
uh russian in essence and sent a bunch
of troops and by the time this airs it
could be that full-on uh invasion has
begun
certainly seems like we're trending that
direction they announced a potential
summit between
putin biden and macron that everyone
knows won't happen if full-on
hostilities occur and the odds of that
again seem pretty high so occasionally i
get asked something it's like hey if you
were president what would you do which
is a reasonable
question yeah you know i ran for
president
uh i i actually remember
you remember this when during one of the
debates they wanted to stick it to me so
they said like what would you say to
putin yeah first call you have no
experience being up here what would you
say to vladimir putin and then i i said
sorry i beat your guy and then i gotta
laugh
thank you but this situation does make
me very very sad
where
putin is aggressively trying to
reconstitute the ussr
uh ukraine has a system of government
that's at least somewhat democratic uh
and
i feel like this
invasion is trying to take advantage of
american
uh vulnerability and instability in part
maybe biden's unpopularity and one of
the interesting things is that uh
in another type of regime
maybe a biden type would say
common enemy russia let's go
but it seems like that's not the tone at
all
it seems like the tone is centered
around
sanctions and punishing
russia economically which is something
that russia and putin i'm sure fully
expect and expected so that that's not
going to dissuade them
in this but you're not seeing this
kind of call to arms feeling at all
where biden is saying okay
sure
things may be kind of
uh faltering a little bit in terms of my
domestic agenda but here's something
americans can rally behind right
it so i will say this i'll preface by
saying we are not experts in
foreign policy or specifically russia
ukraine relations um we should try i'm
going to try and get ian bremer back on
here so i was reading um the rise and
fall of the third reich the fascinating
book on world war ii and basically
hitler coming into power and
one of it's long so those who's like
don't like you read this exactly so dry
i'm sorry but it is long but it's it's
interesting and one of the
biggest things that was happening when
hitler's rise of power was occurring was
he was slowly but surely invading some
of his narrowing country
neighboring countries with like relative
justification like i don't think you can
say yes that's okay but there was like
in the same way russia has right now
it's like hey we do have
territories here or uh they're right
here
or something right those lines we've
made the modern ukraine today russia
russian is the most common language most
popular language i think in ukraine or
one of them at least so
there's like kind of false
justifications there for an invasion
and the rest of the world is like uh
i don't want to go to war for ukrainian
you want to go to war for your criminal
your own it's like that and it feels
like russia knows this is playing chess
a bit where the rest of us are
maybe we're playing checkers i'm not
really sure but they're putting the eu
and us in a situation we're like well we
don't want to put our troops over there
but if russia goes in they're going to
stomp ukraine and take what they want um
and
the question is
what are the consequences of that action
you know what i'm saying if we're doing
nothing which we're probably going to do
we'll do some economic sanctions that
sort of thing but the consequences when
hitler did it were awful because then he
basically bought himself more time to
grow his army and grow his territory and
then he became tougher to beat so
russia's ambition seems to be to
reconstitute the ussr there is a massive
difference between now and the 1940s
where that predated
nuclear weapons where in this case
russia's a nuclear power where nuclear
power there are other nuclear powers
so it becomes much more of a stakes in
judgment question where it's like what
are the stakes is this something that we
will go to conventional war over
and then will the great powers be able
to exercise restraint so that that
conflict doesn't
escalate to something unmanageable or
unconscionable i'm a little bit
surprised that biden isn't taking a more
robust stance here because russia has
been screwing with us very very clearly
for years and years in terms of
hacking our
democracy honestly i mean you know like
russian bots and
interference in the last election and
everything else and when i was running
for president i said look these are acts
of hostility most americans get it and
if you were to say to russia you have to
stop trying to subvert elections and
misinform the american people
misinformation really is one of russia's
go-to moves they're excellent at it so
you should take that as
uh an act of aggression and it's
happening every day from everything we
can see
and then when they supplement that
aggression with
trying to absorb
uh their neighbor and regardless of the
history that ukraine used to be part of
ussr et cetera et cetera i'm not sure
why
biden isn't taking a more this is a
great opportunity for us to
frankly show putin that we're not going
to lay down and have him just expand and
attack and and do things that are
out of bounds
it i mean the calculation seems to be
that
ukraine is not worth
going to war over right from the outside
looking in my question is that well we
don't really have a
public
conflict at the moment right we pulled
out of afghanistan is this
a possible
like you know is this becoming an issue
possibly a whole bunch of
money interests leaning on certain
elected officials is this real is this
you know i mean if that were happening
then i feel like you would see to see
more of a call to arms kind of thing so
we're spending let's call
a trillion dollars a year on the
military i think it's around that
neighborhood
uh and and i've always been
more or less aligned with the
thinking that we're overspending uh that
a lot of the money we're spending isn't
really making us safer
that you wind up with this tail wagging
the dog situation where you have these
mammoth interests in trying to find the
next war to fight those resources could
be better spent in myriad other ways
right so that's my my general outlook
yeah all of that said if you're going to
maintain the world's largest military
and
russia attacks ukraine i think that this
would be an occasion to deeply consider
utilizing that military because if
russia's allowed to
invade ukraine i know this thinking has
been used for all sorts of disastrous
things in times past but if russia is
allowed to conquer ukraine do we really
think putin will be like okay that's it
you know i'm done i'm done
um do you really think that other
powers around the world won't say hmm
turns out when push comes to show the us
really doesn't want to do anything so
maybe i'm going to have my eye on my
neighbor with the natural resources or
the historical tie or whatever it
happens to be
so i i do feel a bit bewildered why the
administration isn't going a bit harder
a betting person would look at the
situation and say that you don't amass
200 000 troops the board of ukraine and
then stop
if you look at the map i mean they've
surrounded all of the east
a good chunk of the
north and about half the south border of
ukraine they basically have like a
crescent moon shape around the country
but it is a chess game make no mistake
um there's more to this than we
understand or no that's not public we as
usual with this administration are
losing the pr battle i'll say that for
sure um and americans are just left like
confused and holding the back which is
why i wanted to talk about it in the
pods like
i don't know what's going on i think the
average person i think the takeaway i
think for folks like us just listening
is like this is a big deal or probably a
big deal definitely potentially a big
deal it is unclear how america is going
to respond but it will affect i think
the next it would definitely affect you
know the time from now to the midterms
for sure if it blows up and and possibly
the rest administration in terms of the
shape of power structures globally i
don't know yeah it just feels like the
u.s is receding and
again if i have a philosophy it is
rebuild yourself at home first not if
you're collapsing at home then nothing
else is going to work
there should be a response that
discourages putin directly and then
someone who's thinking about taking any
kind of similar action towards their
neighbor
you don't want to devolve into a world
where it's just regional strong men
trying to absorb assets and take over
neighboring states are we trending in
that direction generally
it feels like it
in my mind putin's been acting
aggressively and as an adversary really
the u.s for years uh and
now that it's come to this flash point
i i do feel like the u.s
should almost be looking at this as like
okay like this is something very direct
that we can get involved in in a way
that can send a very clear message both
countries us and russia have nuclear
weapons it's this game where if you play
it out there eventually becomes like the
threat of are you gonna nuke me like
that's uh
and that's awful with that logical there
should be a diplomacy option because
it's just mutually assured destruction
right so i don't know it's going to be
fascinating to watch um we will do our
best to try to like parse through
what's real and what's not which is um
because right now you're seeing like
you're seeing like both sides like kind
of uh
i don't think the republican democrats
are truly united on this i think the far
left like no war and the middle left is
like joe biden's gonna be strong and the
right he's like [ __ ] russia but then
there's part of the right that's like
joe biden is reckless foreign like you
know as you've seen those i think our
general
history has been to be a bit too eager
to go to war uh shall we say and i i
think that democrats
have gotten kind of bullied and shamed
into being for conflicts that they
weren't genuinely for because they
didn't want to appear weak
uh hillary's
war authorization vote comes to mind uh
you know like yeah i mean barack ran on
it right and um yeah i mean it it felt
like it wasn't genuine it just seemed
like uh political thing because
democrats don't want to appear weak
so it is funny
where a lot of the things i'm saying are
still cutting against my thinking for
this particular episode
where it's
i mean put put bluntly it's like putin's
been [ __ ] with us for years
uh in ways that have really been very
destructive
uh and now
he's attacking ukraine and if we don't
have uh commensurate response then it
you know what was it all for it's like
that it turns out he weakened the united
states resolved to a point where he can
attack
a neighbor
that there are and you know i think i'm
i'm somewhat
biased on this because i met a bunch of
ukrainians over like the last number of
uh months
yeah just like he's on the trail
yeah just down
about and i've liked them
so
you know i think that that's actually
factoring by thinking a little bit where
it's like i met someone from
uh ukraine the other day and i was like
oh are you concerned and he said right
now his family's not concerned for life
in limb yet but you know the very
emphasis on yet yeah bbc had an
interesting piece in the new york times
today too i like the new york times
generally their foreign reporting their
foreign policy because they have enough
money to put reporters like on the
ground in ukraine and elsewhere um
they're saying most people are not
freaked out but they weren't packing up
to move they're like i'm just gonna get
out of this war zone so they're
confident something will happen and dust
will settle and that sort of thing a lot
of folks they're used to this sadly you
do have a
russia who has been [ __ ] with us to
your point with this information and
high roi activities on social media and
elsewhere
and
we're at a point now where we can't get
any sort of national consensus or
majority behind our
leader that that's a sense that makes us
weak and he and putin is smart putin's
very smart and he understands that so if
you're gonna try and mess with the
united states he's doing it the right
way put that way
so here's a fun fact 90 of coffee from
the grocery store is actually stale
you heard that right the coffee you know
and think you love needs an upgrade so
instead of rebuying the same old same
old let trade coffee send you something
freshly roasted they are literally by
the numbers guaranteed to love so trade
sells the freshest roasted and ethically
sourced beans from america's best
independent roasters so they ship it to
you free as often as you like whole or
ground so if you love coffee this is the
place for you so whether you're a coffee
nerd or just love a better daily cup
trades real coffee experts taste test
over 400 roasts and use tech to match
you to your ideal coffee based on your
preferences and brewing method it's
pretty freaking cool i took the quiz
found out all these different types of
light roast and where it's from the
types of coffee that i like and it's
been great and it comes to me i brew it
up and it's wonderful and frankly you
could save money doing this instead of
spending you know four dollars for a cup
of coffee and some of the places
where we can get let's call it your fast
food coffee if you will this is better
ethically sourced made at home awesome
coffee so right now trade coffee is
offering a total of twenty dollars off
your first three bags when you go to
drinktrade.com
yang so to get started take their quiz
at drinktrade.com
hang and start your journey to your
perfect cup that's drinktrade.com for 20
off your first three bags check it out
[Music]
this is too dark and heavy a
conversation for vacation mode so let's
talk about um i want to talk about
denver because we just went to denver
and like dove into
i'm gonna call it crypto mania um which
i think is a fun perspective i don't
want to dive into web 3 a lot of folks
are not necessarily like into crypto or
that sort of thing per se
um but this was a wild experience uh how
was your your time in denver andrew what
did you learn about
i had a blast it reminded me of a lot of
tech conferences i've been to but turned
up a bit higher yeah they threw you on
main stage last minute which was really
fun
oh i saw a lot of people i knew yeah uh
a lot of the yang gang former yang gang
current yang gang whatever was have gone
into
web 3 which has been fun
yeah so i had a blast i
enjoyed it immensely met a lot of
tremendous entrepreneurs a lot of young
people there's a lot of energy and youth
uh so it makes you
optimistic about the future of the space
because if you have that much ingenuity
and energy then some good things are
going to develop for those who maybe
missed last week's episode um last
thursday's episode we started something
called lobby 3 and the idea is to
get the community of folks interested in
crypto entities and web3 together to
advocate and lobby in dc for
what web 3 can do specifically around
eradicating poverty now
you tweeted about this we had a whole
we're pushing it and we're maybe pushing
next couple weeks we want to build this
up
political twitter did not understand
this and i wanted to address something
because some of our audience is part of
that world you you said and i agree with
this thing is that web3 can or has the
best potential of any tool we have
to eradicate poverty it can't eradicate
poverty and
man blue check twitter was like that
doesn't make any sense you know nothing
right so i wanted to ask you in your
eyes how
what do you mean when you say it can
eradicate poverty how would that work
what ideas are you looking at what
excites you about that you have a space
in an industry that now
has a market cap collectively of
uh over two trillion dollars that did
not exist seven years ago right and i've
met now hundreds of people who've had
their lives transformed economically
including a lot of creators who were
producing things and
were having a hard time accessing the
market because the media market in the
art market in particular very very
narrow and institutionalized
but through
nfts they've been able to command
incomes that they never could have
imagined you can have mechanics where a
creator gets paid for a resale in a way
that was never possible before you start
talking to these folks and you realize
wait a minute like you know some of you
have the equivalent of a universal basic
income some of you have the equivalent
of these kind of social economies that
i
was writing about back in 2017 2018 that
have come alive this is to me one of the
most profound opportunities maybe the
most profound opportunity to fight
poverty
that's on the table right now i mean
what are the other major opportunities
to fight poverty
lobby congress for the enhanced child
tax credit which we're doing but one of
the cases we're making
right now is that dc is kind of broken
and dysfunctional
you know
if that's your situation like you still
try and push push push you know and then
you try to reform the system um but you
also look around and say wait like that
there are whole new economies that are
emerging that are being enabled
by digital currencies and other
innovations
so let's try and make the most of that
and if you have a space that's
worth trillions of dollars one of my
personal ambitions by coming in and
saying look we have to demonstrate that
this can be used to benefit a broader
public than maybe it's perceived to or
maybe that it is right now let's take
a billion and fight some poverty with it
and then show people what can be done i
mean a billion would be a very small
fraction of what's happening in web 3.
so i'm pumped about it so i mean an
example is if you record a song
and it's an nft now
anytime it's played you could get the
pennies yourself instead of funneling it
through spotify or the record labels
which you're talking about giving money
to the masses instead of the few right
instead of the institutional company
web3 could be the middle man killer
and right now the middle men are the
biggest companies in the history of the
world yeah sort of for in some of the
cases you know what i mean and many yeah
in a number of cases so we're going to
do an ama
on friday the 25th is tomorrow if you're
listening to this um when it comes out
on thursday um
with scott saint who's been on this
podcast before but he's working on a
number of projects that
are
versions of ubi and the blockchain but
what like okay zach it's tough to get on
the blockchain how do we do that but
here's what's exciting i'm excited about
and you kind of and i want to pick your
brand in this too because you kind of
talked about this when you ran for mayor
um and it was in your book war on normal
people about digital social credits
which i was like this doesn't make any
sense or this is too crazy um but
the concept is
if you took a neighborhood
that needed an economic lift
and
you said hey here is a
you know
hartford let's say harper can i get one
from hartford coin
and if you spend it in hartford
it's worth 10 times you know you can
return it back for 10 cents on the
dollar so you get 10x of what you ever
pay for what we give you right in terms
of dollars but if you spend it in
hartford in these businesses or
restaurants or whatever local stuff
it's worth
exactly it's worth you know ten times
more than a dollar right and you can get
it back and you can create economic
value
for more than what you paid for and you
can do that on the blockchain because
other folks that live in hartford with
it for wanted their supply and demand
you can control it without having to do
all the formal currency
problems we have in terms of creating
new currencies within the united states
or globally um
talk more about that or how it would
work or if that excites you too
hopefully scott will talk about it too
on our discord and on friday oh yeah i'm
super excited about it because one of
the primary
things you can do
with the blockchain is have what's
called smart money
where it changes properties based upon
uh the type of place you spend it
right yeah like it it like you know that
there's total transparency attached to
it so it's not uh you know it's not not
as prone to corruption and the rest of
it
if you wanted to try and rejuvenate
neighborhoods uh some of them have
already adopted local currencies uh with
some positive results uh uh ithaca i
believe had its own currency there are
different towns that have done this
um in my view in an ideal world
eventually you reach a point where you
it's plug and play where you can have a
local currency some of the things that
i'm most concerned about
right now you have this winner take all
economy the values flowing all up into
the cloud to amazon um you're going to
decimate downtowns and small businesses
yeah already right and that now if you
live in a particular town you know what
you get told a lot buy local and you're
like okay let me do that walk around
brooklyn they'll say buy local yeah and
then that that works on you every once
in a while but then generally speaking
you just take the path of least
resistance yeah uh so what the heck does
the future look like and the future
looks like frankly more and more winner
take all the comme uh economics unless
you had
a way to genuinely
uh reward and reinforce and incentivize
these behaviors that we talk about
but we don't actually reward you for
doing correct you have no incentive
right now unless you're either super
rich
or so
you have to be super rich i think to
start your own boutique fashion store in
brooklyn right now there's not
there's no you're not going to have the
foot the foot traffic you're not going
to have you're going to have all the
expenses and then you'll be competing
with
global conglomerates and people that can
just buy it while sitting on their couch
at home right
so if you added economic incentive to
folks like hey yeah you can buy on
amazon right but if you buy here locally
it's you get 10 times the value and then
like then or if you volunteer at the
local nonprofit and you get this
currency that you can then use and like
the local shops downtown and then like
you actually can start to build yep like
a more robust
uh local economy yep in whole new
imaginative ways managed locally instead
of the federal government being like
this is what's valuable it's like the
people of brooklyn whatever city you're
this is one of the frustrations i have
about our system man it's like
you know it's like all of the economic
flows head in a particular direction
let's say to amazon just to keep things
simple in a way that everyone can
understand
and then you'll have a bunch of folks
you know essentially like paying lip
service to the other thing
um it's not going to work
and we we talk about it just to make
ourselves feel better
so you know you just have to look at the
the actual
economic system it'll lead you to a
predictable outcome now the great thing
is that you can build whole new local
economic systems i mean this could
become like a
you know
like a non-profit executives or museum
executive or
city planner or like local officials
dream yeah dream come true you redo
cities yeah faster than you ever could
have before yeah the frustration i have
is like essentially the people who are
put in that position and you and i know
this is people who ran nonprofits it's
like they're like standing on top of a
sinking ship but all their economic
incentives are just to like talk about
though we can like you know if we all
come together we'll be able to like
create the whole thing
even though
you know and hey i'm not getting paid
enough and like all i do is sing for my
supper so that my organization can stay
afloat until i'm out and the world's
going to disintegrate around me while
i'm like like i mean that's an email
what are they solving nothing right like
they talk um yeah so so what you need is
like is different economic systems
that can be adopted a localized level
and
the blockchain and web 3 are potentially
a very powerful way to do that yes
what we're trying to do is that this is
it's new it's exciting but it means it
is the wild west right now it does need
like sensible regulation and oversight
because
if done wrong there's scams there's done
wrong like you don't want to hurt the
people already vulnerable right with bad
systems that are ineffectively managed
but you also want to empower the right
people to set them up so
um that is the point of lobby three to
figure out ideas like this that can get
people banked for the first time give
them economic incentives locally redo
our broken system
and we need the federal government
and our state governments to really um
understand this be educated on this know
what to advocate for we need the left in
my opinion to be championing the human
side of this right now they're like
krypton
and that's that's destructive to me well
the left in theory
is for uh broader distribution
everything would you say yeah uh it's
for transparency uh it's for
uh trying to
dislodge some of the mega corps
uh and
uh web 3 could be a path to these things
it's just that most folks on the left
have something of a skepticism or
mistrust of
technology and innovation at this point
unfortunately which is something that
you know i'd love to help change and i
get that we're trying to change it
that's what lobby three's doing so if
you wanna check it out we're gonna be
with scott um tomorrow in our discord
you can find the discord it's it's on
lobby three dot io or um on andrew's
twitter profile you can just click the
link click the link um that'll be in the
afternoon it should be up for a while
too so um
anyway super exciting we start minting
we start building this community
on monday upcoming which is
crazy uh we have over i mean by the time
you got this we're gonna be close to
four or five thousand people in the
discord uh and growing which is super
exciting we've got this whole new if
you're into web three join us if you're
not into web three maybe maybe check it
out
or you can ignore it don't worry about
it yeah it's uh
yeah as long as your friends in crypto
know about it you should be okay there's
enough voices there that are excited
about this that we can get behind yeah
hopefully we'll make it obvious a little
bit later
that's true that's one of the things
okay you guys need to stop
sleeping on terrible mattresses and i've
been there before i've had a mattress
like oh it's not that bad it's fine it's
tolerable i got a helix sleep mattress
and it has changed my life it's changed
my back it's changed my sleep it's
changed my mental health it's changed my
energy because a good night's sleep
works
wonders so look helix sleep has this
very simple quiz you can just take two
minutes complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
want a mattress made for anyone else
makes sense with helix you get a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep and they know that
so you have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot it matches great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains they even have a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
like you've got
all your options so i took the helix
quiz i got the mattress i needed that
fits me and it's fantastic so if you're
looking for a mattress take the quiz
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free in this little
highly packaged box and it's wonderful
you never need to go to the mattress
store again so here you go go to
helixsleep.comyang
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life 10 year warranty you
get to try it out free for 100 nights
risk-free totally awesome and right now
they are offering up to 200 off all
mattresses and two free pillows for our
listeners that's helix sleep.com
yang so check it out helixsleep.com
yang
[Music]
this past friday i had a watch party for
the uh forward event in new york city
which you were a part of remember that
night oh yeah i was there
yeah and i made a cameo in that if i
recall yeah i know you're in the video a
little bit so that's one of the things i
hang around the yang universe you know
i'm on the pod i come out i introduce it
once in a while anyway keep going
now so
reliving that night was a lot of fun uh
and i relived it with
you know hundreds of people that decided
to watch it live with us on friday night
and i can't wait for people to see this
recording so if you haven't seen this
recording if you go to forwardparty.com
there it is behind a pay wall right now
it's like 10 buck donation to forward
party which i'm going to say
yeah
um uh but i'm so proud of it i i can't
wait to get it out uh everywhere and you
know eventually it will make its way out
into the the world uh but what a great
night that was man you know like
watching it myself like the producers
did a great job i actually had not seen
the final version have you seen the
final version because i haven't seen the
final file no it's really pretty good
right now they did a very very strong
job so uh yeah i just wanted to say
thank you to everyone who showed up um
and joined the live stream
last week because it was really a joy to
relive it with you and if you weren't
there don't worry about it you know but
do check out the video because i'm
really proud of it it's like
me talking about some of the biggest
ideas from both the presidential and the
launch of the forward party for you know
48 minutes or something along those
lines so so it's the equivalent of like
a netflix special yeah it's like a uh
but it's like half ted talk
it's like double linked with ted talker
so it's half that but in half a bit of
stand up comedy like you yeah i did wax
comedic it's pretty funny because how
are you gonna entertain people for 48
minutes if you're not at least somewhat
funny you know we brought actually i'll
give you this we brought carly's parents
to it that's what i think about i think
about the riley's and they were
they're pretty like you know they're
they're
they're fans of andrews obviously but
they're critical because they've seen
him speak and other things and they were
like
her dad particularly was blown away he
really liked it so um he's a tough guy
to please so that's i'll give you like
some context i think you'll enjoy it's
worth your time and it's very
eye-opening what's going on in the world
uh monday's podcast we had on dr warren
farrell who's the co-author of
the boy crisis why our boys are
struggling what we can do about it and
this is a topic that you're very
passionate about zach we've been talking
this for a while too
and his book just hammers you with
figures and stats and it's just
eye-opening and depressing well i'll
tell you as a dad it certainly made me
feel kind of good about myself because
apparently dads are really [ __ ]
important and all you need to do is show
up that's like the biggest one just show
up that's like i mean i it did make me
feel kind of good on that level where
i'm here like i exist i mean i'm on the
road a lot and i'm pretty busy but my
goal is to stay married man that's a big
one right
so you know i'd have two things i bring
to the table one i exist
and two i rough house
uh rough housing very key um who knew
boys i mean i do so i did it but i
continue to do it but now when i
roughhouse i actually feel like i'm
being a [ __ ] awesome dad so it's a
good it's a good feeling yeah
but the the book was a very bleak
portrait that's getting more bleak uh
this is something that we're going to
continue to hammer
uh because
no one's doing [ __ ] all about it it's
like you know one of like the the main
things not no one but like it's really
not as much of a thing
um as it should be
i i want to change that with the the
forward party it's rare man and i was
looking at um i'll just be transparent i
was looking at guys because we're funded
by
you guys listening and then ads pay to
sell you their [ __ ] and so thank you all
for putting up with our tushy ads etc
um we try to do companies we
use ourselves yeah we're trying to do
companies we actually like we do that
out a lot because so whatever that's
worth um but uh i was looking with our
podcast producers to see if there was
anyone that would be interested in
funding well another episode of the week
or a deep dive into boys and men's
issues and
the the canon answer is like not really
um proctor and gamble sponsors one um
that our our friend liz planck is is on
called i think it's called man enough
but that is um and we've had liz on this
podcast i agree with her on a lot of
things i'm really grateful that she's
actually doing it i don't agree with her
on everything and i think
their version of it is like a leftier
version than um i think better than
nothing but not what you and i have
wanted to talk about like i want to have
a male disintegration and why that's
happening and what they talk about is
how men can reevaluate and change their
relationship with masculinity um and i
think that's part of it but it's deeper
than that and no one's touching
kind of
well what dr farrell saying and what
we've been talking about um
so anyway uh
companies don't want to touch this
because they're all so risk-averse you
know dr farrell
told me about you know some of the
responses he got
and
it i mean
there's something this makes me much
more determined in a sense it's like why
do people attack
people who are concerned
about men and boys there's something
very very odd afoot seriously seriously
right i mean we're talking about like
you know half of humanity like doesn't
make any sense
yeah why dude this guy was like the male
champion for feminism and now he's like
kind of fringe in the way to these
fortune 500 companies he's not getting
the same gigs he was
even when we talk about it we get we got
a lot of positive feedback we get a
bunch of dumb we get [ __ ] all the time
fine but we get a lot of dumb [ __ ] here
like irrational thought on this and uh i
know it's emotional for folks but it's i
watched tinder swindler on netflix uh
last night with evelyn have you seen
tinder swindler i saw the first half
carly watch the whole thing she said
it's mind-blowing i got the gist because
tinder swindler sent a very very
powerful message that this particular
guy was
[ __ ] evil you know which he was
uh and and there were
a number of women he victimized that
were like very very sympathetic figures
right in my view they fell in love with
him yeah
and so one of the messages i think that
when you talk about why it is that
people are attacking people who care
about boys and men um is that they're
seeing so there's a circularity going on
right now it's like you have a lot of
men
who let's say like are not what you want
them to be which certainly like anyone
can see that's happening i mean they're
a lot of [ __ ] and then you're having
them interact with a host of people and
then people think that men are
victimizers abusers
uh criminals hateful then you have
positive
uh wholesome
uh caring men who are doing great things
out there
but unfortunately i think like the ratio
is getting kind of worse over time and
one of the dr warren farrell fan like
arguments is that if you have failed men
they don't get married
so if there are boys who are born they
don't have dads and it turns out dad
deprivation is a massive massive problem
uh and so then you have fewer men out
there that are going to turn into caring
supportive fathers and then like the
cycle just continues and gets worse
right it grows
the vicious cycle where it grows myself
ask yourself right now
how is your mental health
is something preventing you from
achieving your goals is something
interfering with your happiness i want
you guys to check out betterhelp.com
yang i did this myself
i got a therapist
mental health coach and someone i could
confide in and talk about what i'm going
through on a daily basis and it was
game changing life-changing i'd say so
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online so check out better
help you can send a message to your
counselor anytime you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses and plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
whatever is convenient for you so you're
talking about depression or stress or
anxiety or relationships or sleeping
trauma you name it anything you share is
confidential convenient professional and
affordable
so i want you to start living a happier
life today so as a listener you're going
to get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
dot com slash yang
[Music]
you know i think there's a lot of press
on like women that are bucking the trend
and they're bad asses in
entrepreneurship in business and that's
and i think those are good great things
like i like that right that's good for
it's good for women it's good for
society but i don't we don't have um it
doesn't really apply to men that are
good men you know the women that are not
flashy this they stay the course they're
faithful to their wives they work every
day they keep purpose they're great with
their kids they're faithful they're
strong steady caring they do the right
thing you're not seeing much press on
that you know um you see a lot of press
when men descend celebration of decent
manhood
yeah and they're and there are a and the
majority of men are decent but it's
growing a number how many the bad ones
are and we're not when we don't focus on
it you know and that's my fear it's been
my fear this whole time is that men
disintegrating
hurt women um
and they hurt everybody by the numbers
but they'll hurt women the most and the
most vulnerable the most or hurt
themselves
not too that's true which also hurts
women like if you're if you're a father
and you have kids and um and a wife and
you disintegrate into drugs pornography
or mental depression or suicide or if
you're a boy and so i
saw for the first time last week evelyn
did this too she's got his tickets uh we
saw dear evan hansen have you seen dear
evan hansen i have not been on my list i
heard the movie wasn't great um the
movie you saw the play we actually went
and saw the play the play is amazing
yeah that's apparently wonderful i was i
haven't never gotten to him so no i
haven't it was very on point to what
we're talking about right now because
evan hansen is a troubled teen with a
single mom
and the single moms trying trying trying
and very sympathetic um but she doesn't
really get what's going on with her son
and then her her son
has serious struggles and problems and i
felt like a lot of people could relate
to a lot of aspects of
this play
i felt like was very american it was
very of the moment
because i think that there are a lot of
troubled
uh
boys uh male teenagers with single moms
where the mom's trying but doesn't
really get it uh and
uh one of the men that dr
farrell described
um he was raised by his mom and his
aunts
and he hated them which i'm you know
it's like it makes you sad to hear that
um but because of that like he
he just like you know hated
women because like the women in his
lives he didn't have a good relationship
with
um so
there's
something very very important about kind
of interrupting the dynamic that's
building up because you have these boys
and this this uh boy wrote dr farrell
talked about he just didn't have any
structure in his life because i know he
didn't have a father figure or male role
model around uh i like i i do think this
is a microcosm of what is fueling
the disintegration of american life is
that you have a lot of kids growing up
in that kind of environment
and uh and again for whatever reason a
lot of mainstream media like don't want
to look at this as like a struggle like
everything that you see
is around
and these are things i'm for by the way
it's like you know girl succeeding women
succeeding people of color succeeding
like you know people like lgbtq
succeeding like like you get that
message
all the time like you know 100 times a
day kind of thing um and again you could
be like yeah i'm for these things um but
but there is like an aspect that it
seems to be at the expense of someone
uh and it let's say that you are and i
use you always that cause you're so
perfect for it but if you're like uh you
know like a straight white dude
succeeding like anyone celebrating your
success
no not in particular yeah and then we
had our moment it sounds like so you
know or like just like you know that
like you need everyone to succeed like
it doesn't you know like i'm for people
of historically marginalized uh groups
succeeding but i'm for everyone
succeeding and you know for like that
[ __ ] poor white like kid in the
midwest having like a shot at life
instead of like growing up and you know
getting ticked off and eventually
uh you know like just saying like yeah
like you know what's the point i mean
like that that's freaking terrible it's
like heartbreaking it like doesn't
matter
uh who i mean i feel like we've hit this
note before but uh
that this
there has to be a a tough you know like
real talk i suppose about this stuff
um so talking to dr farrell about it is
definitely if anything bolstered my uh
desire to try and make this case in a
way that's productive and lead somewhere
and i was heartened by the fact that
folks grappled with and did not dismiss
like the washington post article oh my
god good you're up you're not bad yeah
yeah i find myself mystified that i'm
somehow becoming like a spokesperson for
american masculinity uh just because it
seems so random
well no one's doing it i mean that's the
point like one of some of these a big
aspect of this andrew is
no one's talking about it and i'm not
i'm not coming at this from a boohoo
zak perspective like no one's
celebrating my success i'm coming out of
perspective is i know guys that if
they feel like they don't have a path
forward or a purpose or they're told
that you're a failure you're the you're
the problem which is a lot of it
they devolve into dark things they they
head the wrong direction that ends up
hurting all the people you're trying to
bump up by the way and um
at worst it's school shootings and
suicides but at best it's
pornography and video games and um
various levels of anger and social media
fire and discord yeah
james said to me james uh treacle who's
uh right behind the camera but he said
that my purpose in american life is to
say the things that people kind of sense
on some level but are not being said
did people did people sense that oh by
the way we're automating away millions
of american jobs and you know we're
going to wind up in dark places and we
should probably start thinking about
universal basic income i think a lot of
people sense that but just like there
was no one whose institutional
incentives were to make the case for it
uh i i feel the same way about
uh boys and men where like a lot of
people census is going on but for
whatever reason there are no
institutional incentives to talk about
it
uh even though it's very very human and
in my mind concerns everyone yep
i talked about ian bremmer earlier but
he had tweeted a graph about um
both the us and china but let's talk
about the u.s particular are having
we're having less babies we're having
less kids which which stands to reason
and i mean is this how tight is i'm
assuming these are oh it's very very
tight right yeah yeah so so check it out
if you have
fewer men who have stable jobs
then you have lower rates of marriage
objectively and now if you are a
non-college graduate you're below 50 in
terms of the odds of you ever being
married which makes me super sad because
you used to be able to think i think
anyone just think of like well
eventually i'll get married
uh so you have fewer marriages than
fewer people having kids
marriage is becoming more of a luxury
item it appears
a time will tell on that and therefore
kids probably will too and you'll still
have kids and with
you know single parents and the like but
i i don't know what are your thoughts on
what that means in the future like what
what happens to societies when they
don't have enough kids do we just uh i'm
assuming two minutes they die off right
it becomes a massive problem and there's
no one to take care of the elderly um
well in the us's case it would be
supplemented by immigration so what
happens in aging societies that don't
have kids the extreme examples japan
where they don't allow anybody
right and then the freaking entire
populations of shrinks and shrinks and
you have massive problems uh the the us
has relatively healthy levels of
immigration
uh recent immigrants have tended out
bigger families by the way too
it's one reason why the makeup of the
country is likely to change
so
uh so in the u.s
you what you'd imagine is that it would
it would
speed up
like a diversifying population
[Music]
in some of these
i said some of these immigrant
communities or something like lower
income communities that the public
services suck public schools sucks
healthcare sucks food sucks like you end
up with more people getting
whether they're buried at the piling up
at the bottom with less economic
economic opportunities to go up and then
you have fewer and fewer at the top even
just by the numbers ignoring the
economic opportunity in some ways just
by sheer
less rich people
existing right but if they're not having
as many babies i don't know
sounds like some hunger games [ __ ]
though to me
well what you said is very bleak my
friend i i will say you you tweeted
something that i thought was really
interesting that bears out um which is
that
the the folks who are going to wind up
uh attending college and graduating from
college are much more likely to be from
uh traditional family units than folks
that are less so and so you'll wind up
with this very very strange partitioning
uh and
and this makes sense really this is like
the the simplest way to like i think
about it is like look uh if you have a
functional family you're more likely to
end up producing uh functional high
achieving kids so then if you have
you know let's say a four-year college
it's going to be disproportionately
comprised of kids from those units
and so that like that that's going to be
in my mind one of like the real
uh
differentiators or conveyors of
privilege and opportunity is like did
you come from
a family with a dad a fan like a
two-parent household and so if you can
swing that then you know the odds of
your outcomes being positive go up
um so interestingly enough like if you
were a school that was truly committed
to diversity you'd be like you know hey
we're going to bring in a bunch of kids
who well you'd actually use family
structure as one of your proxies right
there's there's some challenges that
obviously yeah i'm not i'm not
advocating necessarily but i'm just
suggesting that that's actually going to
be like the one of the biggest engines
of
intergenerational success this is a new
version it's a new definition in a way
of wealth in that
if you have less money and even less
opportunity but a stable family with two
parents that love you
um and are involved in your life
together by the numbers it appears that
you'll have a better chance of success
in moving making actually this is
actually better you're more more likely
to make more than your parents did
economically
than you would if you're coming from
this a single parent or
a version of a broken home and that
we haven't really wrapped our heads
around that as a society um because our
incentives are not there
and so this is the wild thing about it
this you know brings us back full circle
which is
okay like if you wanted to interrupt
that chain what would you be doing you'd
be trying to raise boys that could end
up being strong fathers because it turns
out that dads wind up
uh you know conveying like a degree of
stability and uh development et cetera
et cetera
um
and so that so this is the the wild
thing is that like well how do you get
boys to be on the tournaments like well
you need like you'd prefer them to have
a father figure so like at this point we
should be doing our best to like install
father figures wherever we can um a lot
of it too in my mind would be this is
again the circularity is like well
uh you know for a dad to be around or
for a guy to get to a point where he
gets married like you know you need an
economy that provides stable
opportunities right
if you kick that away then it all
becomes harder i i will say that this
particular line of inquiry that i found
myself in which i knew mostly about
um from my research for the war on
normal people like 2017-2018
um but it's
it it's
now to me like the core struggle
uh and it was around you know one of
like the open questions is whether
something like universal basic income
uh would help like i believe it would um
and one of the reasons why i believe it
would is like people look and be like
hey andrew if you get like guys money
like you know they're just gonna spend
it on nonsense and like it's not going
to make them into like better partners
dads etc and it's like
okay like maybe
um but but one of the things that i
remember reading about was like a family
in west virginia where there was a guy
and he was hurt
and he was trying to work but he was
having a hard time getting a job and
then his relatives were encouraging him
to go on disability
and then that they framed his going on
disability as a way to provide for the
family it's like hey we're gonna be you
gotta provide like uh one of the
problems i think is like a person shows
up what let's say it's like you're you
know younger male cousin or nephew or
whatever and they show up
and they're not worth anything
um so even if they had like universal
basic income it's like hey that person's
now like adding value just by being
there and like and bringing some
economic resources with him
uh
and so that like so this makes me think
that yes i do believe ubi is actually
much more positive than it is negative
in terms of reconstituting a sense of
male value because then the guy shows up
it's like oh it's bringing money with
them it's like you know
it's from that here in your family
who are trying to get this guy to be
like hey you know you got to provide for
the family and in this case that means
getting a disability check right it's
interesting you know what it is in doing
all this research
i've been thinking like probably very
similarly the to the way you thought
when you were looking at the
automation statistics and you're like
wow this is a really big problem someone
should run for president to bring
awareness to this like maybe there's a
world where i think someone could run
for president on the boy crisis um
failing boys and men i think it would
not be that great if it came from the
right
um
but they might win
um
a lot of the stuff right now from the
right is capitalizing on the boy crisis
yes yes that's actually republicans are
great at this they don't talk about the
root of the problem but they will they
will they will fuel up they'll take
advantage of the moment right of the
symptoms yeah fox news has been doing
this for years it was like scare your
grandma piss off your grandpa type stuff
but i agree with you this could be a
pivot issue and like you know what
direction you're running from would be
fascinating uh but i think this would
galvanize millions of people very quick
and you have
versions of this happening and some of
the culture wars the right is is in
flare i'm actually going to make a
predictions act someone is going to run
for president 2024 on this
look at that i think you're right um i
actually know who it's going to be so
all right so there's that cheat code um
occasionally gets cheat codes um
i think they do surprisingly well and i
think my prediction on that is that a
lot more their base is women than men um
not more women than men but a lot more
women than you'd expect um well good you
know great yeah like some of the women
who are the most for
like the stuff i've been putting out
have been uh women yes get it you say
get it any mother of a son totally gets
it any da any son that grew up without
the right real male role model and then
found one that's kind of the key they
usually get it too they're like oh wow
completely i think a lot of women get it
because a lot of women are seeing the
symptoms of it and being like yo like
that that's not great yeah oh my
goodness anyway on more positive note
we're out here in puerto rico
let's go back to the sun
we are going back to the sun we're going
to the beach guys i hope you do
i recommend taking a vacation somewhere
warm or if you're in somewhere cold in
the months of january to march um
so
glad we're able to do it and kind of
share house it up um
but anyway
closing thoughts andrew we rocking and
rolling you know love peace
brotherhood sisterhood
love peace we love you
what do they have any good expressions
in puerto rico like in hawaii it's like
mahalo i don't know
um i'll give up we should cut this
episode we love you guys
see you next time
[Music]
you